I was talking to a buddy of mine named
Tom schnauz who's one of my writers now
my oldest friend he and I went to NYU
film school together and he and I had
written together on the X-Files around
2004 it had been off the air for two
years he and I were bemoaning the fact
that we couldn't get another really
great TV job but uh nothing uh writing
wise was forthcoming so we're talking
about should we you know go work at H R
Block should we dig ditches and I said
you know what are we going to do now and
he said uh that maybe we should uh build
our own meth lab in the back of an RV
and drive around and make some money on
the side what was interesting is that in
the moment he made that joke this idea
for this character who would do such a
thing became of great interest to me
someone like us who for whatever reason
actually did such a thing actually
decided to to cook meth I didn't have a
name for him yet but led to that
character who would eventually be known
as Walter White I think I was really
interested in writing a story about a
guy having the world's worst midlife
crisis I thought what if it wasn't a
midlife crisis whatever if it was an end
of life crisis